Hey look at the new version Carla oh hey
look it's a new version of God let's
play it wheat you'd gauntlet I played
this game so much when I was a kid I'm
Apple 2 GS all right try now I'm gonna
go elf okay i can move now i'm just
gonna take a warrior skin up yeah do it
so i got the timer they'll have me what
happens when you car we got you great
and it's all down your door wiring steam
so i'm getting all of the achievements
by rats what's most important I'm a
wizard Harry all right i got the s
horror charge I'm the green dudes we're
in the world one do I have on be oh I
got a shield throw slamma jamma so
everyone's got the leg oh well shop we
don't need to go there hmm wait stour
need to be talking to the shop man i
already completed the first section okay
we gotta to you sure yeah you sure yeah
okay yeah yeah what is your great Danny
what's a barrel roll I don't know if
there's a barrel roll okay on the green
dude at Chris who are you blue dude blue
lady airtec warrior which is what that
red okay and that means yellow for you
rob roy oh I'm purple okay Rob's
colorblind okay it's definitely not a
purple character Rob I'm joking after
you had an eye test recently wasn't that
great all right I'm gonna kill everyone
with these up I'll explode uh fun fact--
here that cleave icon for my wire looks
eerily similar to Diablos oh yeah like
is it you really what is it like creepy
and kooky yeah sure cookie dough
whirlwind it then any you guys play the
original gauntlet back in the arc 80
days not sorry Caitlin I mean I played
the original or watching a tallit that
came onto my Apple 2 GS oh yeah yeah so
much of it was it hard it was hard once
you got to like the higher levels and
you'd like it find out the fine word of
the warp zones works he didn't want to
play every level and then Oh each shield
and then you are you've encountered
excess much
up Oh who's dead ye press a to revive
back in my book was it you live again
you did encounter death who is just this
black clothes character whenever we
would be on screen it will be on screen
it would just go so in addition to feel
that's the way it was man this is a
realistic portrayal of gaming history
gamespot is legit website so we pull
that up can we verify that chris is not
let's not do it ok I can hear my side
she's around the office than people want
oh that was good so these are like
monster back closets basically where you
have to destroy and my standard attacker
won't work in them so only my charged
our one will so maybe it's the same for
you guys no I'm basically just jumping
on it I'm lankan I guess it's cuz my
like I can spam my arrows so much and so
i played this on my own earlier mmhmm
yeah it was good fun y'all still stand
in the way of vengeance we are clearly
like burning through these areas I got a
little Boop I got a little like I had to
lay there for dealing sixty percent of
the damaged oh yeah to the enemy
generator hopefully i get this you're
that guy hun Danny you're the guy that
meets the turkey when you probably
didn't even need it yeah well that's why
I'm like the most overweight of all you
guys like I like all the slightly life
like video games I always eat the turkey
leg yeah I really just go to a turkey
and pick off all the skin and that's it
in they go nice all we need a key is it
this way oh yeah they totally used to
have these barriers your keys are
through with the key you know Drake guys
ready clip out of existence ready you
lie I'm use my special I'm gonna leave
is my special jr. species mine too BAM
guys let's get it coordinated why they
just died all I know in our clothes have
to coordinate all right like you that's
it I'll just take all the gold guys
don't worry about it like a ludus Ludo
Oh what I'm there I don't know some sort
of the enemies when they hit you can
like knock you back and I've been in
situations where i got knocked back
straight into another enemy
so you can lose a bunch of that house
real quick yeah I just got knocked back
quite a shield all over you you did all
right remember your stuff that's all I
died to say he has cooled down these my
health is low other's abilities and died
too I don't I got too cavalier well
that's because you're freaking
backpedaling with your ranged yeah it's
it's kind of it's a cup of sugar Oh your
wish what did you what did you turn I'm
okay I'm gonna be whisking all right on
top until I back baby I thought again
you just robbed all my stuff yep sorry
that's what you get for taking that
turkey leg that I needed earlier just
walk it off Merlin you're like that guy
back in the day playing ninja turtles
that always ate the pizza when they
didn't you too yeah I always ate the
pizza when I didn't need to life I'm a
ninja turtles anyone got key up as in
our life so in Ninja Turtles I've got a
key you guys are gonna lie gonna drop a
bomb do it damn it great that was real
good your blue it O'Dwyer oh I died for
my sins yeah girly to go that was Karma
am i'm gonna say he's gonna steal the
gold and the turkey oh i got charged
Shay O'Dwyer Touche so this games going
to pretty soon it's like I said next
week next week okay thanks for caring
for today and it's a lot of fun yeah
it's it's it's it's pretty good I feel
like I was having fun with it earlier
playing on my own and I do think it's
maybe a red wizard come over here and
get this Turkey it's a pot collaboration
I mean ya know where's know the other
fun oh well red you're talking about me
sweet da Silva turkey
purple dude maybe my purple guy is not
shown up the whole time at this first
section the first like Dora unlocked and
took like a good on my own at least solo
took like twenty five minutes and it
seems to be like 15 or so in that main
area but this problem man there's also
like a classic word or something right
don't you want to see the classic mode
aiming at this is really funny classic
modes amazing for graphics check this
site oh yeah I see it already it's
bringing roses oh this is terrible do it
this is not good at all wrecking my date
was great it actually looks way better
when it wasn't this back in the day
think we just walked by much of gold
because it's just changing your graphics
this just looks like kind of an exam
quake Wars you do it again so mushy yeah
this is terrible can we enter key
retrace way to anyone who liked it I
love hey even the UI is like playful huh
oh god hey got my oh it's like a pro
contacts by game I can see you again I
just kill that lady which I oh oh is
that the Bob to get the boss oh yeah
whoa where your legs dude I pull the
chopping are you gonna Rosa laughs Rosa
done jumped up chop chop chop chop chop
oh thank for that gold oh no I just get
hit by the enemies laser beam green the
green thing with me got a little bomb
yeah ow it won't hurt you oh I got froze
I got froze in place by this enemy lace
up watch out smash she's a fire in our
lasers was also someone dude oh I just
died they killed or taken kick at least
an affair enemy variety in jibo levels
to give me the loot no plunder my body
did I
where what happened last time Oh No I
love gold it's okay guys I got all the
gold for us okay are you gonna spend it
all at the shop yeah at the bar oh
that's your just stereotyping oops
somebody set something on fire you can
carry that yeah you can pick him up with
a I want to do and if some jerk sets it
on fire before hand Oh Rob beautiful oh
I didn't do anything she just laughed at
the idea and this is completely
accessory asian lady that's out how
we're gonna tell me she'll eat turkey
and Charlie's way okay oh all right tell
your elf that Oh lean meat you know
through it also makes you like sleepy a
rookie guys there's been mom thing does
it if i use this is that I'm is that a
monkey island reference oh god I'm stuck
in my balm area oh geez everything you
want it that depend on the goal it's
okay oh man this guy charged me twice
like a box Oh shield always whirlwind
whoa oh god I got I got crossfire will I
get unlimited lives a limited corners
Chris limited quarters yeah we're grown
adults now we can afford video games now
that when i was playing this on my
computer with a joystick and a single
button there also were two buttons cuz
he would use magic and you would you do
your attack you guys don't want this
chest up here i'll take it oh he's
probably global right i would assume so
I mean it doesn't show us and jump off
the screen individually I'd found the
girl blue and green I'll wait the Turk
uh this will keep me in the fight so
we'll defiling sarcophagi oh yeah do it
I couldn't do it they didn't they didn't
get I haven't level up my defiling skill
yet ah what about your plundering like
pillage the deads oh here we go here's
some eSports is gonna be who's it gonna
be oh I took one oh boy peanut stand
stand the jump thing you guys can do
that right he's known I be his whirlwind
oh really I'd be a
shield oh then that then those sections
are way easier for me Oh typical oh I'm
dead I'll whisk
I suppose we ought to cancel for his
attacks down oh he's still alive so yeah
what's allowed Keri soon as we all die
away Rosie now I think it's fine I dis
revived yeah yes we should all
concentrate on the same area did you
guys off so at the past like a bunch of
that glow ends there's been m oh [ __ ]
i'm dead man trucks yeah those food
trucks yeah text we just really see
people around them to the turkey like
all walking around with giant turkey
legs did you guys ever get any turkey
legs no you're gone forever I know that
the the homeless people word and
definitely feasting all right look good
they're feasting on those two wonderful
doing good for the neighbor up the lumo
even the people watching open hand baby
they have project right I was actually
just messing watch out for the bomb all
that bomb is dead okay alright which
stone are we going for it top or bottom
nacht ich to that farts I'm dead yeah
let's concentrate on Oh took out that
although top ones actually spawning wait
worse oh god I just got rocked come on
Merlyn mom like me the great was I get
to a man ah yes if we all die yeah we
alone for everybody I did blew it on you
it i was on you buddy that was on knows
your hero moment shame shame you almost
had it I'm a real peel we're almost
there real POS go cry later good well
hey I'll we're back to the start all
right let's not do that then alright
what else is when I let's go masteries
like all these sweet stuff we get a lot
hmm that's hot wooten food and death
dawn and online as well gauntlets it's
good fun right this is [ __ ] who
agrees had that smash TV kind of vibe
yeah gauntlet it's a gauntlet I've I
know plenty gauntlet yeah and I play the
old gauntlet either uh Rogers i
mentioned that i did play the old
gauntlet actually yeah ok maybe didn't
say that during this ad lagana Rob
didn't write it Rob's 12 you guys want
to play that like n64 gauntlet there was
like a third-person action view I was it
like the bomberman act 0 of the gondolas
series yes no was yeah
ah was it great there was a dude the
Warriors had this move called blazed a
trail that you would like shoot this
triangle of power they're like you know
like everyone but the audio like was the
voice acting for was bad she was like
brother brewer every time what did you
say visible precursor to fus ro dah yeah
it accepts like mush mouth that version
we shouldn't we should play that one the
mergers are so so bad
you